son innocence et cette fois il fait face
à la justice fédérale rien de moins que
37 chefs d'accusation dont plusieurs
font sursautés après avoir quitté la
Maison Blanche il aurait délibérément
gardé plus d'une centaine de documents
confidentiels en sa possession parmi ces
documents des secrets nucléaires
américains et des informations
militaires sur les États-Unis et
quelques alliés dont le Canada en
demandant à un assistant de les cacher
de ses avocats et du FBI il aurait
complété en vue d'entraver la justice et
surtout il aurait nuit à la sécurité
nationale
l'ancien président et ses alliés
continue de décrier une chasse aux
sorcières politiques
a fait ses commentaires avant de
démissionner aujourd'hui de l'équipe de
Trump en compagnie d'un autre avocat
leurs arguments sont de la foutaise dit
celui qui représentait les démocrates
lors du premier procès pour destituer
Trump
Mans qui aspire lui aussi à être le
candidat républicain à la présidentielle
l'an prochain déplore les accusations
Donald Trump est dans l'embarras
plusieurs de ses actes d'accusation
pourrait lui valoir 20 ans de prison à
eux seuls ils comparaîtra mardi à Miami
ici jean-Sébastien Cloutier Radio-Canada
Montréal